good afternoon of the rules
committee for Monday June twenty
fourth is hereby called for our
future visor audio and video
recording stage proceed is being
made there's also be televised a
man sector please call the roll
Cooley here Cunningham Carillo
Grayson here Kamlager-Dove
Maienschein Mathis quirk Silva
Ramos Rivas Wicks
we have a quorum and we have a
consent agenda -- is for most
of the consent agenda -- by
Mister Cunningham seconded
by his works thank you very
much -- ma'am sector please
call the roll Cooley Cooley
aye Cunningham Cunningham I.
Carillo flora Lara aye Grayson
aye Grayson aye Kamlager-Dove
time Kamlager-Dove I Maienschein
Maienschein aye Mathis Mathis
I look so much all right
select Ramos I read this
Rivas aye works fine
the motion passed and --
that concludes this will